[Applaudissements]
c'était hier soir juste après son
élection une vigne on retrouvait ses
soutiens rose rouge vert le vert sa
boisson favorite
la candidate endosser un nouveau costume
comment on m'appelle madame la maire je
suis mère dans ma fonction je suis
parent je suis la mère ce matin dans les
couloirs feutrés de la mairie anne
vignot est déjà au travail en tête à
tête avec jean louis fousseret le maire
sortant une passation de pouvoir en
toute discrétion
c'est important de savoir garder le lien
avec les personnes qui ont fabriqué la
ville qui ont participé à sa fabrication
l'ancien maire laisse deux objets une
marianne et ce sous main en cuir se
souvient c'était celui de jean majeau il
a fait les montagnes d'argent ensuite il
a fait les mollahs de robert green 24
ans toute la construction de besançon
depuis les années 50 c'était signé ici
sur ce souvent lorsque je disais bonnave
la veille a peut-être besoin peut-être
dire d'adaptateurs le cirage mais enfin
c'est symbolique
est ce l'effet du premier jour tout
arrive en même temps le tableau de bord
s'emballe il faut préparer conseiller
municipal la rentrée scolaire est elle
très fait qui m'a appelé aussi donc je
pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
choses effectivement à envisager
donc il ya beaucoup trop
puis c'est au tour du directeur des
services de l'emmener dans une autre
salle plusieurs dossiers doivent être
traités dans la semaine c'est la
continuité du service public qui est en
jeu votre couleur quelques heures à
peine pour assimiler les plus gros
dossiers des problématiques de marché
des problématiques de travaux des
problématiques de programmes de
réalisation l'intégration du nouveau
programme qui a été approuvé hier soir
par les bisontines et les bisontins
voilà ça nécessite effectivement un peu
de travail
c'était le premier kilomètre de sa vie
de mère le début d'une course qui doit
durer six ans